I came home one day and there was no
note no nothing but some of her clothes
were gone and the house felt different I
made uh about three calls and on the
third call I got her sister and she said
Karen's in Santa Barbara with her mother
doesn't want to speak to you for a week
she wants to get her head together we
never argued I had no clue what caused
anything and this just hit you hard it
hit me so hard and I was just spinning
and I'd bought a shotgun for Karen to
have it as protection in the house but
you got that dark I got the gun and put
it against my head were you really
thinking about I was going to pull pull
the trigger but my I had a dog a little
dog called Angel and Angel lay on my
foot and I would I thought if I kill
myself what happens to angel is she
going to starve to death maybe I should
put some food down so I Put the gun down
first and then I thought what the
am I doing